hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my guardians of the galaxy to video
we might know who the villain is
Elizabeth - Vicki might be playing yes
oh I'm gonna explain who that is and
it's gonna change who some of the other
characters are like we're not sure who
Peter Quill's father's gonna be that
also has a lot to do with who this
villain is fathers and children are
supposed to be a big theme of the movie
gomorrah is the daughter of Thanos
they're gonna continue that line even
though he's not gonna be a big presence
in the film they're gonna deal with the
idea of it finding out who Peter Quill's
father is so let's start with the
villain first so Elizabeth - Vicki is
rumored to be playing the main villain
of the film the rumor is she's playing a
Yesha who's like this genetically
engineered soulmate for Adam warlock
that possesses this really cosmic soul
that's super powerful one of the reasons
people think it's legitimate is because
Adam warlock could be a part of the
movie without actually being a part of
the movie here's where it gets a little
complicated because guardians is really
tied up with the idea of Thanos his
quest to form the Infinity Gauntlet the
infinity gems Adam warlock possessed the
soul gem in the comics that's where
Thanos got it from but because the movie
seems like it's not going to be doing
him and it seems like the soul gem is
gonna appear in one of the other movies
we just had to find another candidate
for Peter Quill's father and then when
they cast Kurt Russell everyone's like
oh that's got to be him almost any
version of any character that Kurt
Russell has played on-screen could be a
version of Peter Quill's father so
here's where things start to line up a
little bit in the comics a Yesha has a
son with quasar named star hawk Marvel's
version of that character is a big part
of the guardians of the galaxy comics
but he's also a big part of the new
guardians comic that debuted in 2014
called guardians 3000 the working title
of guardians of the galaxy 2 is
guardians 3000 so a lot of people are
taking that to be clues that Peter
Quill's father is going to be star hawk
so Peter Quill's grandmother will be a
Yesha and that will explain how he has
this cosmic DNA enabling him to handle
an infinity stone without being
vaporized so remembering that the movies
change little bits about comic book
storylines I'm not expecting them to do
anything really big but if they're going
to use an infinity gem that guardians
3,000 story this star hawk just came
back in actually involves a very
Groundhog Day type situation even
backstory reads like he's connected to
the time gem his life is kind of like a
groundhog state situation where he's
destined to be reincarnated as a baby
and relive events over and over I don't
know if the movies gonna end up doing it
this way but in the comics Starhawk goes
back it's like reincarnated as a baby
but he still retains all the knowledge
of the future he uses that to his
advantage to try and change the events
of the future and that just sounds like
a slam dunk Time gem story but beyond
that really like the only big things
that we know about guardians of the
galaxy - are that Peter quill is gonna
find out who his father is we might see
an infinity gem and we're gonna meet a
couple new crew members I mean we have
dancing baby Groot still addressed the
regrown version of Groot Mantis is
joining the crew if you don't know who
the Mantis character is she's another
non-human member of the guardians of the
galaxy in the comics so the interesting
thing about this assuming that the
villain is going to be a Yesha that's
who this really is gonna be she's gonna
be Peter Quill's grandmother the twist
is in the comics she's not typically
thought of as a villain so the real
question is is what her motivation is
what it is that she wants that puts her
in opposition to the heroes but I am
expecting a few changes from comic book
versions of characters because we're
talking about beings with vast cosmic
powers and we saw the collector in the
first movie he's one of the elders of
the universe incredibly powerful in the
comics but when we saw him on screen
he seemed relatively normal so we might
CD powered versions of some of these
crazy comic book characters but you can
kind of see matically where Peter quill
is gonna encounter his biological family
and he's gonna have to choose between
them and his adopted family the
Guardians so I'm expecting a very
lovable charming version of Kurt
Russell in this movie
yondu talked about him in the first
movie like he was an just as
much of an as Peter quill is so
you can see how funny it's gonna be when
scoundrel Peter quill meets his father
who's an even bigger scoundrel but I
know a lot of you are confused by it all
because Peter Quill's father in the
comics is JSON of spartax James Gunn
already said that he's not going to be
doing it that way just because he
doesn't wanted to do this sport oi
Empire there's a couple big space
empires that Marvel can't do just
because Fox owns the rights let me know
in the comments based on a Yesha
being the villain do you think that that
means Peter Quill's father is going to
be Starhawk because previously a lot of
people were like maybe the he'll be
Yosef Titan who's the
of Thanos so they'll connect it to the
villain in that way but when we found
out that Thanos wasn't going to be in
the movie and then we found out this
might be the villain it kind of shifted
that so given all those things it does
sound plausible that Starhawk is his dad
and it totally sounds like a character
that Kurt Russell could pull off and it
sounds really awesome on screen the
funny thing about Marvel movies is
they're made to be very broad very
simple concepts like regardless of what
the plot is or whatever complex ideas
are presented you could take a little
kid to the movie and he'd be able to
absorb the emotional story like a son
meeting his dad for the first time
learning that maybe he's not the nicest
guy in the world maybe he's better off
with his adopted family the guardians of
the galaxy but guardians is like the Big
Spring Marvel movie next year so we'll
probably see the first trailer later
this summer when we get closer to Doctor
Strange Marvel skipped San Diego
comic-con last year and to this date
they have not announced a Hall H panel
yet so I'm not expecting any big Marvel
movie footage at Comic Con this summer
so they might just wait for dr. strange
to drop all this new stuff but here's my
other big question even though we're not
gonna have fan o's in the movie do you
think we're gonna see an infinity gem
because there are a couple more movies
before we get infinity War part 1 and
I'm wondering if they're gonna hold one
of the gems to the first part of that or
if we'll see the time gem and the soul
gem before then because there's two more
gems that we haven't seen yet so
currently there are just a couple
objects that Marvel could use that would
be stand-ins for the gems like they use
the tesseract as the space gem so if
they're gonna do a gem and Guardians 2
they could use the star brand they could
use the time gem to explain how it is
star hawk has this Groundhog's Day type
life where he gets reincarnated over and
over they could introduce the soul gem
and Doctor Strange they could also
introduce it during Thor Ragnarok just
because the villain of that movie is
gonna be so powerful it seems like
they're saving the rest of the gems for
really overpowered characters in movies
so that's why we didn't see it in Civil
War because they wanted it to feel very
human so it was like a list Avenger
versus a list Avenger instead of a God
versus a God like you see in Thor
Ragnarok so let me know where you think
we're gonna see those other two gems
because I definitely think we're gonna
see a gendering Thor Ragnarok but what's
gonna happen next is I just saw a ninja
turtle so I'm going into an Easter Egg
video be sure to subscribe to get that
I'll post it tomorrow I'll put a spoiler
warning on it but if you've seen the 80s
cartoon
then you totally know what's happening
you totally know about Krang Technodrome
all that stuff it was a lot of fun so be
sure to check it out
while you guys wait for me to post that
video you can click here to learn all
about Marvel's Civil War - and you can
click here to learn all about the flash
season 3 doing flashpoint thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you